[Music]
on this friday night september scorcher
the high pressure system it's like a
bully you can't kick it out punishing
western canada and the u.s the
conservative leadership race nears the
finish line what to expect and one
candidate's pledge about plain language
plus stream dream
how amazon is banking on hobbits and
hemlocks to beef up its bottom line
and the summit series became more than
just one hockey team trying to beat the
other how the historic tournament
changed hockey forever
global national with bara nasser
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us well it's upon us the friday before
the last long weekend of the summer and
get ready for a scorcher a u.s heat dome
broiling california is going to have an
impact on canada's labor day weekend
tonight more than 23 million across the
u.s and parts of canada are under heat
warnings and as heather urex west
explains tonight in our top story in
some areas like bc and the prairies
it won't just be hot it could be
dangerous
in death valley california record
breaking heat 53 degrees celsius the
hottest day ever on record for september
it is actually dangerous and it would be
dangerous to break down here yeah i'm
extremely hot right now just standing
here i don't know
the punishing heat settling over most of
the western united states fueling a
devastating fire north of los angeles
the route fire has already consumed more
than two thousand square hectares
injuring at least seven firefighters who
tried to hold it back
a lengthy heat wave is now putting so
much pressure on california's
electricity grid officials warn rolling
blackouts may begin in the days ahead a
dangerous situation created by a heat
dome it's a large area of high pressure
area
that sits over the
large piece of real estate and doesn't
move it's like a bully you can't kick it
out and its influence stretching up into
parts of canada sections of southern
alberta and southern saskatchewan could
see temperatures on saturday into the
mid to high 30s smashing previous
records
heat warnings are already in effect in
many parts of bc and alberta heading
into the long weekend officials warning
that spending too much time outside can
be dangerous especially for the elderly
children and pets
once relatively rare intense and
long-lasting heat domes are becoming
more common in many parts of the world
so far we've seen a number of these
events in pakistan had one in
in the spring as well a really intense
heat wave so i think we're seeing the
impact of climate change
and you're quite right that if we don't
change our carbon footprint
these events are going to become more
extreme
the short term good news is that across
western canada temperatures should begin
to cool by the start of next week
heather urex west global news calgary
seven people have been injured an
explosion at a refinery in come by
chance newfoundland and labrador now we
don't know many details at this time but
police say one person's injuries are
serious and that the incident happened
just after 4 p.m two hours later breyer
renewable fuels said the incident had
been contained
russia will not restart the flow of
natural gas to germany it's blaming an
oil leak at a pumping station as the
reason all this as concern continues
around the zaparisia nuclear power plant
six inspectors are at the site now and
there were concerns by ukraine that they
were not given full access to the site
but as redmond shannon reports the head
of the mission says that's not the case
international nuclear inspectors walking
past russian military vehicles inside
zaparisia nuclear power plant
new footage released friday of
thursday's long-awaited inspection
mission
a russian official shows the
international atomic energy agency team
the damage on site but all of this video
comes from russian broadcasters
speaking to western media back in vienna
iaea boss rafael grassi says the damage
remains a top concern impact holes
markings on on buildings of
cell
his worry is that the power supply
needed to cool the plant could be
interrupted again he dismissed concerns
raised by ukraine that his team was not
given full access we've seen what i
requested to see
everything i requested to see grassy
says six inspectors are still at the
facility and two will remain
indefinitely his responsibility to keep
them safe may mean he holds back on
criticizing russia
rossi says their presence is invaluable
as russia and ukraine continue to blame
each other for the ongoing shelling in
the area
it is no longer a matter of
a said this and b
said the country
now the iaea is there
ukraine's nuclear energy company says
one reactor is now back online after
russian shelling disrupted supply
thursday
but energy supply concerns aren't
confined to ukraine russian energy giant
gazprom says an oil leak at a compressor
station means the supply of natural gas
to germany will not resume saturday as
scheduled the company blamed western
sanctions for the maintenance hold up
giving no date for a resumption of
supply just as summer ends and as
natural gas prices are at record highs
if they stay that way for winter
europe's resolve in supporting ukraine
will be severely tested redmond shannon
global news london
political giant mikhail gorbachev will
be laid to rest tomorrow but he will not
be given a state funeral
and russian president vladimir putin who
paid his respects to gorbachev on
thursday will not attend the funeral the
snub shows the kremlin's ambivalence to
credit gorbachev for his role in ending
the cold war putin blames gorbachev for
not blocking nato's expansion eastward
it's a point of contention that played a
major role in russia's current invasion
of ukraine
u.s president joe biden took explicit
aim at his predecessor in a rare prime
time address last night in the speech
biden said donald trump and the extreme
ideology of the manga republicans
threatens the very foundation of our
republic
there's no question
that the republican party today is
dominated driven and intimidated
by donald trump and the migrant
republicans
and that is a threat to this country
biden spoke from the city known as the
birthplace of american democracy
philadelphia he says americans are
facing a choice between democracy and
donald trump natha garcia reports
i ran for president because i believe
we're in a battle for the soul of this
nation
i still believe that to be true a few
minutes into thursday night's rare prime
time address the president directly
named donald trump completely deviating
from past avoidance of saying his name
donald trump and the migrant republicans
represented extremism
that threatens the very foundations of
our republic
biden emphasizing not all republicans
are to blame but saying those who
support trump are embracing anger and
chaos
niagara republicans do not respect the
constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
they did not recognize the will of the
people
they refused to accept the results of a
free election the white house insisting
this speech wasn't political when it had
all the hallmarks of just that says
political analyst dan casino you say
this is an unprecedented threat to
democracy these are by far the strongest
words we've heard out of president biden
he's saying there's no negotiating with
these people he's done trying to build
consensus and he calls on voters to
reject them completely in the november
elections
meanwhile gop leaders are accusing
democrats and biden of being divisive
joe biden and the radical left in
washington are dismantling americans
democracy
before our very eyes
the speech comes as trump is wrapped up
in a legal battle with the u.s justice
department requesting an independent
third party review of documents seized
from his florida home perhaps part of
the reason why as democrats pushed to
hold on to power biden chose slamming
trump instead of abortion as the
strongest defense against republicans
the speech was sort of more focused on
those other arguments as opposed to the
abortion one which to me is the
democrats best argument in this election
and there are new details regarding that
trump hearing friday afternoon the judge
overseeing it released a more detailed
list of what was found at his home
including more than 40 empty folders
marked classified with no indication of
where the information they contain went
all key developments at a critical time
with the labor day weekend kicking off
the final race to the november midterms
which could be make or break for both
sides farah
garcia in washington thank you neethu
in just over a week the federal
conservatives will have their new leader
the five candidates have all but wrapped
up their campaigns and now it's time for
party members to make their choice to
set up the final week and beyond we're
joined by our chief political
correspondent david aiken david what are
we looking for
well first of all this race is setting
records for participation
678 000 eligible voters for 678 000 that
is a record by a long shot and as of
yesterday
395 000 had mailed in their ballot now
the deadline to get those ballots in
tuesday 5 p.m eastern time it is a
ranked ballot the winner needs 50
percent plus one in any particular
ballot pierre pauliev the ontario mp the
former harper cabinet minister he is
still the clear favorite so much so he
might win it on just one ballot
david speaking of pauliev he said this
week that if he ever does become pm he's
going to introduce a new law requiring
federal bureaucrats to speak in plain
language so what's behind that
right pollya believes that bureaucrats
who use too many technical or academic
terms are a barrier to growth he says
difficult to understand laws and
regulations adds costs to small
businesses so
he vows to pass what he calls the plain
language act
the
employees use the simplest and fewest
words possible to describe what they're
saying in their government publications
[Music]
i mean david whoever wins if it's him or
someone else they're gonna have to get
to work quickly because parliament
resumes in just over two weeks so what's
the top priority going to be for the new
leader
well i've been told by a few campaigns
that the new leader will be less worried
about parliament and caucus
much more worried about some systems at
party hq the fundraising arm of the
party not as efficient as it should be
it needs some work the database system
that tracks supporters has been old and
out of date for two elections at least
and by comparison the liberals are using
very sophisticated voter tracking
software and i'll tell you what it shows
at election time so the conservatives
right now they're at a huge disadvantage
in this critical area fixing it could
take 12 to 18 months it's going to cost
the party several million dollars but
that is work the new leader must make a
top priority in order to have the best
shot at winning the next general
election farah sounds like it's going to
be a heavy load for whoever takes over
david aiken in ottawa thank you david
a powerful political figures rush with
death coming up the failed assassination
attempt caught on camera
in flood stricken pakistan aid efforts
are stepping up but millions of people
are still stranded waiting for help to
arrive
today alone pakistan's armed forces
rescued two thousand people trapped by
floodwaters but the death toll surged
more than 1200 people are now known to
have died critical supplies are
trickling in but the country's biggest
charity says roughly 90 percent of the
33 million people affected have not been
reached waterborne diseases are
spreading among those displaced by the
disaster and now there are fears of food
shortages after almost half the
country's crops washed away
argentina's vice president is lucky to
be alive today following a failed
assassination attempt that was caught on
video
but it shows the terrifying moment a gun
emerged from a crowd of supporters
outside the one azerius home of vice
president christina fernandez the gunman
then pulls the trigger inches from her
face argentina's president confirmed the
gun was loaded with five bullets but it
failed to fire the gunman was quickly
rushed by security personnel and members
of the crowd who had gathered there to
show support for fernandez as she faces
corruption charges the 35 year old was
taken into custody and police say his
motive is still unclear
myanmar's deposed former leader aung
sang tsuchi has been sentenced to an
additional three years in jail with hard
labor
tsuchi is convicted of sending a safe
configuration to proceed into a
tomorrow's launch attempt
nasa says it's ready for round two as it
prepares to try once more to launch a
rocket toward the moon the agency was
forced to postpone the launch after a
pair of technical issues earlier this
week if all goes to plan the flight will
blast off tomorrow sending the orion on
a six-week test flight around the moon
and back
fantasy fans are already finding their
way back to middle earth after amazon's
new lord of the rings series debuted on
its streaming service thursday night
it's being called the most expensive
show in tv history with each episode
costing get this nearly 60 million
dollars as mike armstrong explains it's
a major offensive in the streaming wars
that may have more to do with the
company's retail business
[Music]
[Applause]
it would be impossible to accuse amazon
of not taking a big swing
just buying the rights to the lord of
the rings cost a reported 250 million
dollars u.s it's already looking at five
seasons possibly a spin-off and a price
tag of about a billion dollars
it was extraordinary cost aside the cast
is promising a strong story you're going
to laugh you're going to cry you're
going to have all the feels is what i
would say well said
we thought our joys would be an ending
the new show the rings of power is a
prequel to the oscar-winning movies it's
set thousands of years prior it's
actually based on a series of appendices
from lord of the rings not a standalone
tolkien book but it has fans and that's
why amazon is shelling out so much money
it's trying to create a franchise to
anchor amazon prime video subscribers
much in the same way competing streaming
service disney plus takes advantage of
its popular franchises if you're a star
wars fan if if you're a marvel fan you
can't go anywhere this is you've got to
have this service
now attracting and holding onto
subscribers is only part of the story
most amazon prime video subscribers get
their memberships as a throw in for
signing up for amazon prime's delivery
service streaming is about keeping those
200 million customers happy and spending
prime members spend a lot of money in
amazon store
other streaming services also work to
monetize subscribers in other ways
netflix is moving into gaming
disney's doing it with amusement parks
over the summer it's been letting
subscribers in early and offering
substantially discounted tickets so that
means the disney plus subscriber who's
worth let's say seventy dollars a year
uh is now worth thousands of dollars a
year to just
now the biggest part of amazon's
business is retail well its biggest
retail competitor is getting into
streaming walmart announced a deal
earlier this month where people who sign
up for its online delivery service
will get paramount plus for free mike
armstrong global news
competitive swimming's governing body
has approved the use of a specialized
swim cap designed for afro hair
the covering was banned from last year's
olympics in part because the
international swimming federation
reportedly said the caps did not fit the
natural form of the head many swimmers
criticized the comments sparking a
review which concluded that there was no
advantage to be gained from using them
soul cap a company that sells the caps
called the decision a huge step forward
toward improving inclusion in the sport
today marks the 50th anniversary of an
event that definitively changed canada's
biggest sport the 1972 summit series was
billed as a bitter battle on the ice
team canada facing off against the
soviet union in an eight-game roller
coaster that captured the fascination of
millions but for many it was more than
just hockey decades later the game's
legacy can still be felt eric sorenson
looks back at the iconic battle on and
off the ice
the 72 summit series is steeped in
hockey lore canada and the soviet union
the seminal matchup of the two great
hockey powers and the iconic players on
both teams in this country it was an
opportunity to affirm canada's hockey
supremacy against the backdrop of the
cold war
back then we didn't know a lot about the
soviets they were this scary image it
became
more than just one hockey team trying to
beat the other it was proving that our
system was better than our their system
for decades canada did reign supreme at
the olympics and in the amateur hockey
world but by the 1960s the soviet union
dominated their best could play while
canadian professionals weren't allowed
so this series was our chance finally to
prove our best were the best
scoring in the opening seconds canada
looked unstoppable i think we had a
smugness with goals quickly by esposito
and that it just seemed like you know
canada was vindicated we were the hockey
capital of the world what happened next
would change how the sport itself was
viewed the soviets stormed back to take
charge of the game and the series in
vancouver canadian fans booed their
heroes
canada of course with grit and
determination proved their mettle when
the series moved to moscow
they were playing for their country now
and a huge amount of pride as hockey
players and as canadians was on the line
so i think that might be the greatest
thing about the canadian team is it
showed resiliency and it showed the
ability to come back um from from
something where they you know look to be
a national disaster but what the summit
revealed was that international hockey
was indeed worthy competition it changed
and there was more respect for the
international players the north american
game itself got better with the infusion
of russians and others europeans were
welcomed to the nhl
eventually the iron curtain came down
and so the
hockey world became a much bigger and
open place as a result of that series
september 1972 was a roller coaster of
emotions for hockey fans
and without giving away the ending the
summit series did show that canadian
hockey at times can be the best in the
world eric sorensen global news toronto
what a triumph for our country that's
global national for this friday night
i'm farah nasser and on behalf of our
whole crew here i want to thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us
tonight's york canada is the sunset in
point o barrel ontario courtesy of
global's own calling christy who by the
way is going to be at the anchor desk
tomorrow we love seeing your canada so
please keep emailing us your photos at
viewers
globalnational.com until friday take
care of yourselves and each other have a
wonderful and safe weekend good night
[Music]